because Joe Lycett you you like social
media I'm obsessed with it yeah I spend
too much time on it by agree I am quite
sensitive to as well an Instagram I find
to be a lot nice I don't know why that
is I think maybe because it's a visual
based but I yeah and I the thing is I'm
a bit of a [ __ ] on Instagram really
because I so you'll find this now that
you're on it's now gonna follow you yes
do please
you also do selfies with celebrities oh
my god yeah yeah I love to my selfies
and celebrities but you you have a
particular way of doing them yeah cuz I
think you know everyone's gonna do like
a and all of that stuff and I don't want
those so I I like to have a drink with
celebrities as we are doing this evening
so I'll often hold the glass directly in
front of the face of the person I'm
taking the picture it's a good it's a
good game we've got we've got some here
so this is now you know who that is you
know who that is Stephen do i yes I
couldn't guess it either
Oh does anyone know who that is well
you're right who's up next who's up next
there who's that Philip Larkin no it
anyone very well done and the final ones
easy the final vault easy who's that I
love doing because it's so rude but we
thought we could do a kind of a triple
whammy for you tonight yes please using
one of our cameras yeah I've got a
special wine glass that we can all fit
in hang on to the thing and we all yes
they're in there and they're like that
yes we're in now
[Applause]
Nikki Graham's problems got worse Oh big
I'll leave that there hope that's
absolute happen thank you guys for doing
that
[Music]